so in a way you're making an argue
you're making an anti-trump argument I
think because your argument basically is
he could open maybe he sort of did this
and it needed to happen the person but
he might open up the gates of hell here
right like if if he gets to the two of
them and it's like DeSantis is winning
on policy and you know it he feels
fresher and it's right and there's a
track record but Trump is willing to do
the craziest [ __ ] known to man which I
think we would all agree he would do and
again I voted for the guy and I think
you right so that says some that says
something about Humanity I suppose it
does and it's something very dark
you know Ben Shapiro he says facts don't
care about your feelings quite assuredly
he does and he gets a hundred plus
thousand retweets on Twitter he pins it
and all of the conservatives smugly pet
each other on the back in their victory
of how smart they are in reality and but
they're not wrong they're not wrong but
but I say this rather derisively because
feelings don't care about your facts